welcome to this video playing Killian
again Kerala will demora
one of my most frequent opponents okay
it's not really really that I know this
opening in any detail or for that matter
at all but okay it looks may be in place
similar to Carl's Nia in this in the
match he took on c6 even even unprovoked
we should be three for a trade maybe at
least this is a very healthy structure
for white knight takes maybe Knight
takes not sure about this a pawn is
something that I can play against like
this maybe Quincy 291 c3 this kind of
idea or it's the stupid maybe maybe it's
stupid would be interesting to see he
definitely has more experience with this
position type yeah yeah yeah no I cannot
check this a for pawn but didn't want to
do this really I mean when I said yes
more experience the reason is that I
have zero experience with this so I'm
going to try to trade this night
let me let me treat this yeah he doesn't
allow that for good good reason probably
for that hmm maybe I can prepare a form
but he will play a 5 maybe yeah maybe a
5 yeah it's a complicated position and
not clear to me really what's going on
some end games are certainly nice when
they form could be could be weak I'm not
sure it places a very direct way maybe
maybe the right way but you don't know
though I don't know should age 3 is
threatened
the night coming to f4 is a really
really no sense maybe still Bishop age
three a cheeky five get this this rook
into the game first Bishop takes 95
should be quite good and now I have 94
maybe coming or not
still this Knight f4 move that is really
annoying yeah okay I want to prepare g3
now GG 3h for ng3 maybe
Ruka 894 and then g3 is a good attacking
player that could be could be really
tricky
one of those rare cases we have a much
higher rating than than than him
I'm down for in our mini match 7 out of
18 okay here we go
you queen g6 sir this is very dangerous
to put it mildly okay if I don't take it
I'm definitely lost check yeah Brooke a
form maybe rook aged King age - okay
drive
I am looking for I have rookie 4 as well
and 94 not totally convinced that I'm
losing here no Knight e4 this northern
Queen Queen here and mate and here I
have to do that nothing else but exact I
don't don't see how I'm losing which is
probably my own shortcoming when
shortcomings hitting me but I don't see
it takes rook at home it's it's still
definitely dangerous but I don't see how
I'm losing her name
Group G form rook age three and then
Queen e2 takes Knight takes Knight
493 and still this should hold it really
should hold
no I definitely I don't see it I don't
don't see you in fam but all it's always
tricky but f Queen e2 and rookie for
those kind of defensive moves so this
will happen if he plays some some slo-mo
feel like that's a g5 or something and I
can play Queen e2 or rookie form Jack
Jack rupee form or Queen e2 let's say on
h5 Queen e2 is finishing the whole thing
the sacrifice was wasn't wait wait wait
look f3 is still possible rook F 3 but
Queeny Queeny fighters winning then okay
with Queen Queen check here
no not it's not really winning yes look
a fade which I forgot time warning
rookie for maybe rookie for
now it seems to when I didn't plan it
but it seems to win I just get the porn
it's no mage that's really really
surprising
jack-jack
check wait what the heck what did I do
here
that was stupid and still wins but that
was like completely unnecessary check
check check
good luck it's fun I was a stupid move
at the end but ok I only had two seconds
and it was the the main thing yeah
this was he really had an attack either
but I don't I don't think that sacrifice
worked I'm not sure queen g6 is winning
okay this is it looked fishy right this
is it was really dangerous really
dangerous around here so probably this
isn't isn't good then neither for me and
green g6 would have killed me instead g3
and now this with Knight h3 check no
this move of course not to e8 yeah and
this is sorry about that this is the the
killing thread Jim yeah I'm lost here
there is nothing to do I do this this
one check
yeah yeah and this is okay so yeah I
have a at the moment I have a fantastic
run here yeah it's it's it's quite funny
you can look at this here my recent
games they were all there were all wins
yeah it was really nice
Ted ten out of ten I think three five
yeah
ten ten in a row ten in a row I think
that was one where the pune just
disconnected
yeah and he I was lucky when he took on
g2 this was not not a winner it's just
to draw it seems Jackie O
Krysia for even for even winning even
winning a jacket out how exactly look g4
is a win okay and then aged five it's
surprising at least to me check this
loses so okay let's have a look here I
guess the check was aa this move jacket
hi okay so I cannot do this if I play
Queen e2 is still there's the check
sacrificed because I'm losing the house
okay so this was the killer beats that
means that here I have to go to g1 funny
enough hmm this is a draw according to
the computer
checkmate is a very important point
means that black plays this for a draw
how crazy is that English house those
checks for zero well okay this was a
tough fight and the lucky lucky win for
me thanks for watching